Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 181. Ich bin's, Tim Pritlove. Und heute dreht sich mal wieder alles um die Kultur, die ja immer so schön mit der Gesellschaft im Zusammenhang steht. Und trotz alledem geht es irgendwie auch um Technik. Heute mal wieder der Versuch eines kleinen philosophischen Gesprächs. Und ich begrüße Aram, Aram Bartholl. Hallo. Eine Weile gedauert, bis wir uns hier mal zusammengefunden haben. Ich weiß nicht, vor wie vielen Jahren ich es schon mal angeregt habe, dass wir mal dieses Gespräch führen sollten. Aber naja, man braucht manchmal auch ein bisschen Anlauf für so was. Ich hab noch keine Ahnung, wie ich diese Sendung nennen soll, aber irgendwie gibt es so zwei Worte, die mir immer gleich in den Sinn kommen. Wenn ich mir so anschaue, was du immer so treibst, und das ist natürlich so die Realität und die Virtualität, das ist bei dir so ein bisschen das Thema. Kann man das so sagen?
Ja, das ist, also man gibt diese klassischen Begriffe, Begriffspärchen dafür, analog, digital, real, virtuell. Ich rede auch immer gerne, also das greift irgendwie alles nicht so richtig. Ja, das greift nicht vor allen Dingen, weil wir so bestimmte Bilder damit assoziieren. Und das ist auch, wenn ich irgendwo die Sachen, die ich arbeite, vorstelle und Vortrag halte, dann erkläre ich das am Anfang auch immer gleich. Oder wir müssen über diese Begriffe gleich sofern reden, dass natürlich alles, was ich mache, ist real. Wenn ich den ganzen Tag Fernsehen gucke, ist das meine Realität. Wenn ich den ganzen Tag Facebook, weiß ich nicht, klicke, dann ist das meine Realität. Und sofern, ja, und am Ende geht es mir eigentlich eher um dieses Verhältnis von, ich gucke eigentlich viel am Tag auf diese verschiedenen großen Rechtecke mit den kleinen Pixeln da drin und dann laufen wir immer noch auf der Straße rum und gehen einkaufen oder man trifft sich und gibt sich die Hand. Also das ist sozusagen dieser ganz konkrete Unterschied, wie wir kommunizieren, weil wir machen es eh alles so. Also diese Differenzierung zu machen, das ist jetzt ganz virtuell und das hier ist ja ganz real. Das ist sozusagen eigentlich Quatsch, weil das eh so einander schon längst greift oder immer mehr sich sozusagen vermischt.
Aber trotzdem ist ja diese Differenz irgendwie immer noch das Thema. Also auch wenn man sich das politische Geschehen anschaut, da ist immer noch so ein Großteil dieser Verdammung. Ja, der sitzt ja nur vor dem Internet und das kann ja nichts werden. Und die Jugend von heute, die beschäftigt sich ja nur noch mit so abstrakten Zeuchen, verliert ja ganz den Bezug zur Realität. Auf der anderen Seite sitzen dann so die Jugendlichen und behaupten dasselbe von den Politikern, weil sie das nicht tun.
Aber im Endeffekt ist es ja genau das, was jetzt passiert, zumindest auch vor allem im letzten Jahr, angefangen von Google-Street-View-Diskussionen oder Facebook, Google, die Krake, Blablabla-Diskussionen, wo einfach jetzt in der Breite der Gesellschaft klar geworden ist, dass bestimmte Dinge, die im Netz sich entwickelt haben, Auswirkungen haben und dann jetzt ganz klar die ganzen Revolutionen im arabischen Raum und der ganze Kram und Cable Gates. Also es hat sich ja ein Ding nacheinander gekommen und es ist ja auch gerade eigentlich ganz nett zu merken, wie dann auch sozusagen anfangen, die Sachen auszufallen, irgendwelche Cloud-Teile oder Playstation-Netzwerke, wo man immer so denkt, das ist so gegeben, das funktioniert und...
Die Volatilität des virtuellen. Aber bevor wir da jetzt noch ein bisschen tiefer einsteigen, vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen zu dir, wohnst du ja auch in Berlin, wir kennen uns jetzt, glaube ich, auch schon seit 10 Jahren, ne? Als das so losging bei dir, oder? Also du bist Künstler, darf man das sagen?
Genau, ja. Jaja, das ist richtig. Ich höre es auch immer ganz unterschiedlich vorgestellt, ne?
Aber so stellst du dich selber vor?
Also ich bin 1995 nach Berlin gekommen, ursprünglich aus Bremen, das hört man bestimmt auch, habe hier Architektur studiert, an der UDK, und dann eigentlich nach dem Studium keine Architektur mehr, also auch in dem Feld nicht mehr gearbeitet.
Das scheint bei allen Architekten so zu sein.
Ja, genau. Einer der vielen, die dann irgendwie was anderes machen. Das ist vor allen Dingen in Berlin auch, legt es auf der Hand, also angefangen dabei, dass die Architektur eigentlich ziemlich öde ist, die hier passiert ist in den letzten 20 Jahren. Und nee, aber es war sowieso, als ich angefangen habe zu studieren, 95, da ging es ja gerade los mit dem Web und das war natürlich alles viel interessanter. Und insofern habe ich mich auch, und an der UDK konnte man im Studium auch so ein Prinzip machen, was man wollte. Also wir haben Filme und Computerspiel-Kram gemacht und halt viel mit Klicken und 3D und so. Und am Ende, ich habe im Hauptstudium glaube ich kein einziges Haus mehr entworfen sozusagen und dann hat sich das so entfernt sozusagen aus der Ecke. Nichtsdestotrotz halte ich das, ist schon natürlich ein spannendes Feld, aber wirklich sozusagen Architektur machen zu wollen, bis man da sozusagen ein Haus auch baut, was man selber entworfen hat und so. Das sind alles so lange Wege. Dann macht natürlich der digitale Raum viel mehr Spaß und schneller und so. Genau, aber ich denke, ich habe dich natürlich wie wahrscheinlich viele dich dann immer kennen, aber du nicht immer alle kennst, die ich natürlich schon lange rumlaufen sehen auf dem Kongress immer, aber wann wir uns sozusagen so richtig kennengelernt haben.
Du hast mich irgendwie nach Blinkenleits, glaube ich, mal angesprochen, als du mit diesem Paper-Pixel, den du da auf dem Kongress warst, oder so?
Ja, ja, bestimmt. Genau, damals.
Was so ein bisschen Blinkenleits inspiriert war.
Auf jeden Fall, ja. Also da hat es so ein bisschen angefangen bei mir auch. Also ich habe nach dem Studium alles Mögliche gemacht, eben so viel Webkram und auch bis Computer-Wartung und ich weiß nicht, was für Jobs. Aber dieses, so unter anderem, genau, eure Blinkenleits-Aktion, das war schon auch natürlich irgendwie, ja, sehr da, also es hat in unterschiedlichen Richtungen angefangen, aber ein Teil meiner Arbeit sind eben diese analogen Pixel-Projekte und das hat da sicherlich ihr sozusagen die Inspiration gehabt damals und es war immer so diese Idee, wie baue ich das nochmal noch einfacher bzw. noch low-taggiger, als ihr das damals gemacht habt mit diesen Bauschirnwerfern und dann gab es eben dieses Projekt, genau, das ist so ein 8x8-Pixel-Screen, das ist irgendwie ein Quadrat und 50 oder 60 Zentimeter oder so ein Quadrat und ich kann jeden Pixel einzeln ansteuern über so ein breites Lochkartenband, was da durchläuft und ganz klassisch sozusagen die Lochstreifensteuerung, die es ja nun für alles Mögliche gegeben hat und auch schon ganz lange, aber meines Wissens nie für Bildschirme sozusagen und das ist eigentlich, ja, jeder Pixel wird da konstant beleuchtet und nur das Loch sozusagen steuert.
Das wäre ja auch für Blinkenlats ein doch mal ein geiles Intervall. Dass man einfach nochmal so einen Lochstreifen-Ticker irgendwie vor's Haus stellt und dann einfach so die Dinger da so durchlaufen lässt. Das wird gar nicht so schwierig zu machen.
Da musst du uns was überlegen.
Ja, man muss nur Blinkenlats-Protokoll sprechen, dann geht das. Tja, na gut, aber hier soll es eigentlich gar nicht so sehr um Blinkenlats gehen. Dann war aber irgendwie klar, auf dem Künstlerpfad bleibst du.
Ja, das hat sich so langsam herausgebildet. Es gab immer Projekte, die künstlerisch waren. Ich habe am Anfang auch relativ kurz nach dem Diplom diese Handy-Tasche gemacht, Silvacell, was ein kleiner Beutel ist, wo man das Handy reintut. Dann ist es so ein Pharellischer Käfig, dann ist das Ding komplett abgeblockt. Damit bin ich auch mal auf den Kongress herumgelaufen und das war dann immer so damals an dieser Grenze, ja, das ist jetzt so ein Longtail-Produkt, was ich vielleicht im Netz verkaufe und jetzt heute ist es bei mir. Es ist ganz lustig, die Arbeit, jetzt ist es sozusagen eine Edition von, ich weiß nicht, 50 Stück oder so gibt es davon, am Ende. Die letzten, die was gekauft haben, das war so eine norwegische Security-Firma, wo ich dann, ich sag denen immer, ja, hier, das Material kann man da und da bestellen im Internet und macht die euch selber, weil ich verkaufe die als Kunstprojekte und das ist euch viel zu teuer. Und dann schreiben die eine Woche nichts und dann, ja, wir wollen trotzdem fünf Stück haben. Ja, das haben die so einen nummerierten Ding an mit Aram Bartholl.
Echt?
Signiert. Ja, super. Und machen irgendwie, ja, Bodyguards oder ich weiß nicht was.
Und dann damit war es dann irgendwie klar, ich meine, im Prinzip, gut, Paper Pixel ist noch ein bisschen was anderes, aber so dieses, das Mobilfunkgerät in einen Feridation-Käfig reinstecken, das ist natürlich schon so ein bisschen so ein Spiel, so mit diesem, ja, weiß gar nicht, wie kann man das deuten, muss man das überhaupt deuten?
Ja, das ist sozusagen schon dieses Spiel, das ist, also was mir da drängt, ja klar, die einen sagen immer, so mach doch aus, sondern dann gibt es eben diese Geschichte, ja klar, das Handy ist nicht unbedingt aus, wenn du es ausmachst, so, die, auch der wahrscheinlich der Hörerkreis hier weiß natürlich irgendwie, dass in bestimmten Kreisen werden immer die Akkus rausgenommen, wenn man zu so und so welchen Treffen geht oder Diplomaten, was auch immer. Also es gibt tatsächlich eine Funktion dafür und gleichzeitig geht es mir um dieses Symbolische, dass du halt diese einfache Tasche hast und man kann eben noch durch den Stoff sogar noch durchgucken und trotzdem ist das Gerät dann tot und es ist natürlich diese ständige Konnektivität, die wir haben, das ist ja heute ja noch viel mehr, das habe ich irgendwie 2002 oder so gemacht und es ist ja noch viel extremer geworden alles, oder hat sich entwickelt und sozusagen dieses kleine Objekt oder diese einfache, auf eine Art sozusagen altes Format als Tasche knockt das Handy halt aus.
Das ist auch so wunderbar absurd, dass man sozusagen im eingeschalteten Zustand da reinsteckt, damit es dann da nicht funktioniert. So, also ob man sich eine Brille kauft und die dann vorne zuklebt.
Es gibt so Panikbrillen, oder? Ach nee, das war auch so, war das nicht so ein Woody Allen Film oder so?
Es gibt die Gefahr-O-Sensomatik im Paranas durch die Galaxis. Das ist so eine Brille, die dann wirklich in dem Moment, wo wirklich was dramatisches passiert, schwarz wird, damit du da nicht so beunruhigt wirst.
Was ich nicht weiß, macht mich nicht heiß.
Ja, aber dann bist du ja irgendwann, das erste Ding, wo ich gesehen habe, wie du einfach auch bewusst so diese virtuelle Welt richtig in die reale Welt geholt hast, war eigentlich so diese Sache mit diesen Google Maps Pins, oder? Das hat ja auch enorme Bekanntschaft erfahren.
Genau, das habe ich irgendwie in 2006.
Wie hieß das?
Das Ding heißt einfach nur MAP. Manchmal gibt man so einen Titel, dann ist der Titel auf der Arbeit und dann denkt man nachher, da hätte man vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen genaueren Titel. Aber ich fand, das kommt natürlich von Google MAP. Ich nenne ihn auch immer Google MAP Marker. Es hieß irgendwie, ich glaube, es heißt MAP, weil dann dieses Spiel ist mit, wo ist die Karte und leben wir eigentlich auf der Karte? Oder wie stark ist die Realität?
Schreib mal, was du gemacht hast.
Ja genau, der MAP Marker, die kennen wir alle. Also die Suchergebnisse werden ja dann von A bis F durchnummeriert, die ersten 10. Und dann gibt es diese Nadeln auf der Karte im Browser.
Diese Barten.
Genau, das kommt ja im Prinzip auch tatsächlich entlehnt von der Nadel aus, die man sozusagen an die Wand steckt. Das wirft dann auch diese kleinen Dinger, werfen Schatten auf die Karte, auf Satelliten bilden, man zoomt rein und irgendwie werden sie sozusagen Teil der Stadt. Die Sprechblase, die dann da dran hängt, wirft auch einen Schatten und so. Und ich habe die angefangen zu bauen damals in 2006. Die sind sechs Meter hoch, der erste war so ein Holzgerüst, was dann bespannt ist mit Stoff. Also dieses schwarze Rahmen und roter Hintergrund und dann das A da drauf für den ersten Treffer. Und den in Berlin mal an zwei, drei Stellen aufgestellt, eher temporär. Die Arbeit ist jetzt, ich bin gerade aus Tallinn wieder gekommen vorgestern, da ist eine Ausstellung im Kumu-Museum, da wird die gezeigt, jetzt die nächsten drei, vier Monate. Das ist sozusagen schon richtig gebaut jetzt aus Holz. Hat auch so eine Tiefe von 20 Zentimetern oder so. Und ist schon so ein fettes, großes Ding, was dann da...
Also auch noch viel größer oder was?
Ja, nee, noch größer geworden. Das ist erstmal nicht... Es gibt jetzt so Anfragen aus Liverpool, haben welche gefragt, für permanent installation, also das tatsächlich sozusagen, sich da für lange hinzustellen, wo ich auch gedacht, ja, dann kann man es auch mal ein bisschen größer machen vielleicht noch.
Aber du bist ja damit auch unterwegs gewesen. Was hast du denn da so für Reaktionen eingesucht?
Ja, und die Arbeit, also du hast es schon richtig angesprochen, die ist sozusagen symbolisch, erklärt sie ziemlich genau oder ist sozusagen ziemlich direkt, was ich oft mache, dass ich Situationen oder Objekte aus, wie auch immer, dem digitalen Raum sozusagen überführe oder nochmal neu implantiere, ich weiß nicht, im realen Raum nochmal aufführe. Und die Reaktionen sind, also das Publikum teilt sich immer auch bei diesen ganzen Game-Sachen in natürlich die, die es kennen irgendwie. Die sind dann oft begeistert. Also klassischerweise werden diese Projekte natürlich wieder im Netz vor allem, also im Internet dann auch wieder wahrgenommen durch die Dokumentation. Aber interessant ist eigentlich, dass man mit den Leuten am Ende sozusagen auf der Straße steht und darüber diskutiert, was gerade passiert oder was man macht. Und das eben nicht in irgendeinem Blog einträgt, ein Forum macht. Also das ist sozusagen dann natürlich auch mit Leuten, die das dann gar nicht checken oder eben im Digital, die weit sozusagen ganz woanders stehen. Und man dann da, je nachdem, wo man sowas macht, auch ganz unterschiedliche Diskussionen führt und Reaktionen bekommt und so. Und der Google-Map-Marker, das kennen schon sehr viele Leute, muss man sagen. Das Ding. Und interessant ist auch, dass es immer wieder problematisch ist mit den Genehmigungen. Also jetzt in Tallinn war es total schwierig. In Frankreich zeige ich es im Sommer in Arel. Das ist so ein Foto-Festival. Die machen auch so Internet-Sachen dieses Jahr. Und die Bürgermeister wollen das dann nicht auf ihrem Marktplatz haben. Das Spiel hat sich dann als zweite Stufe hinzuentwickelt, dass ich den da aufstelle, wo Google das Zentrum für die Stadt setzt. Ich weiß gar nicht, Berlin ist irgendwo am Alexanderplatz, mitten auf der Straße so ungefähr. Wo ist die Stadt? Hier ist die Stadt. Genau hier ist die Stadt. Dann zoomt man so rein. Und manchmal, je nachdem, welcher Google-Mitarbeiter das da gemacht hat, haben die das in so einem doch eher entfernteren Zoom-Faktor irgendwo reingedonnert. Oder wenn es in New York ist, dann ist es genau auf dem Times Square oder so. Aber so eine kleine Stadt in Frankreich...
Berlin ist mitten auf der Straße. Beim Alexanderplatz.
Aber eben am Alexanderplatz. Also in Berlin könnte man sich ja streiten. Also es gibt ja mehrere...
Da muss man sich sogar darüber streiten in Berlin. Weil eigentlich gibt es da gar keine Mitte. Eigentlich müsste es zwei Suchergebnisse geben. Nämlich Ost-Berlin und West-Berlin. Und vielleicht auch Tourist-Berlin, damit der Potsdamer Platz auch noch eine Bar gekriegt.
Aber das Symbolische ist, so wie der Bürgermeister an Aral, die wollen das dann da nicht haben. Ich glaube unter anderem, das sieht so geowned aus. Bei Google. Und das ist auch, was es symbolisch interessant macht.
Meinst du wirklich, das ist der Grund?
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe auch Fotos gesehen. In Tallinn, da war irgendwie. So Argumentation, da geht es nicht, weil der Verkehr sei zu abgelenkt, was natürlich total Unfug ist.
Überall Werbung, dann stört auf einmal ein A.
Und ich glaube, dass das auch eine Rolle spielt.
Ist das dann schon so eine Verstörung? Also ich meine, begreifen die denn überhaupt, was es ist in dem Moment? Oder reden die einfach nur abstrakt über irgendein Objekt, was da rumsteht?
Ich höre das ja immer nur von den Veranstaltern. Deswegen kann ich es nicht genau nachvollziehen. Aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass in Frankreich, in so einer Kleinstadt, dass die natürlich dann eher das wissen, was das ist, und dass die die Story dazugehören und dann das eigentlich lieber nicht haben wollen. Weil irgendwelche komischen Skulpturen haben sie dann da schon auch stehen. Also es geht nicht so sehr darum, dass da was steht. Aber es geht natürlich dann auch immer darum, was. Aber insofern finde ich, dass das ja auch so ist.
Hury Street, wir haben sie. Das hat sie jetzt wohl nicht besonders gestört.
Aber nur ein Stück, oder?
Ich muss hier gerade mal warten. Das ist halt so mitten in diesem prehistorischen... Ach so, das kann sein, dass hier nur die... Ah, die haben nur Fotos. Na ja, na ja, die Verstörung.
Ja, genau. Und ich meine, der Effekt oder das, was mir daran Spaß macht, oder auch die Idee ist, dass du durch die Stadt läufst und siehst dieses Ding oder vielleicht auch irgendwas aus dem Computerspiel und siehst so, hey, warte mal, das kenne ich doch total gut, aber das gehört überhaupt nicht hier hin. Und das ist sozusagen dieser Bruch. Wir überbrücken natürlich selber die ganze Zeit dieses, ich kann jetzt hier, hier kann ich noch, weiß ich nicht, E-Mail chatten, twittern, drehe mich um, rede mit jemandem, dann poste ich was auf eine Webseite und dann gehe ich mir eine Zeitung kaufen oder so. Das geht alles Hand in Hand, da denkt man nicht mehr drüber nach, aber die Sachen, wir haben trotzdem eine ziemlich dezidierte, unterschiedliche Erwartungshaltung, wo was normalerweise passiert. Und das Ding gehört natürlich eigentlich nicht in den öffentlichen Raum.
Was ich so krass daran finde, ist, das Ding hat ja eine unglaubliche Präsenz. Wenn man so direkt davor steht, ich schaue mir gerade auch nochmal diese Fotos an. Ich habe es ehrlich gesagt live noch gar nicht gesehen, aber das ist ja offensichtlich, das Ding ist einfach riesig. Das ist immer so ein Witz aus Werbung, Science-Fiction-Filmen, wie sich auf einmal die Virtualität in die Realität einblendet. Der Terminator wird auf einmal reingebeamt mit seiner Stromkugel oder andere Dinge morphen auf einmal so um eine rum. Aber man ist sicher, dass das im normalen Leben so nicht passiert. Und dann passiert es dann aber doch, zumindest in so einem kleinen Ding. Meine Blinkenleits war auch so ein bisschen ähnlich, weil die Leute ja nicht erwarten, dass so ein Haus einer auf einmal so anblingt. Geschweige denn irgendwie so interaktiv dann auch noch so reagiert. Das hatte schon merkwürdige Folgen, hatte ich mal so den Eindruck. Also die Leute waren irgendwie auf eine ganz merkwürdige Art und Weise berührt oder verstört.
Ja, weil das eben genau die Erwartung halt nicht entspricht und so wie ich das vorhin sagte, der Bürgermeister, die wollen es, also meine Vermutungen wollen es nicht haben, weil es dann so Google-präsent aussieht. Aber es symbolisiert eben sehr stark die Größe, die das sozusagen hat. Also da kann man jetzt wieder anfangen, über Google zu diskutieren, aber einfach nur oder was auch immer das dann ist, das ist ja sozusagen auch ersetzbar oder austauschbar mit irgendwas ganz anderem, die Wichtigkeit, die das erlangt hat und wie wir da drüber selber Realität bauen.
Ich meine, Google scheint es schon so ein bisschen angetan zu haben. Das ist ja so ein wiederkehrendes Ding.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Da gibt es ein paar Projekte dazu. Ich weiß gar nicht genau, warum. Also naja, schon, weil es präsent ist jetzt nicht so... Ich will es unbedingt mit Google-Arbeiten machen. Ich glaube schon...
Ich denke, Google hat halt schon die prägenden Dienste der Frühzeit dieses Wandels, dieses 21. Jahrhunderts gebracht.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also die Suche an sich ist ja schon sehr stark. Google, das ist ja in der Sprache drin. Und gerade Google Maps, denke ich mal, und Street View war ja dann eigentlich nur der nächste Schritt. Da ist ja im Prinzip vielleicht zwei interessante Begebnisse.
Ja, die sind dann auch so entstanden. Also einmal gibt es... Das haben wir 2010 bei der Transmediale mit Fat Lab gemacht, dieses Google Street View Auto, das Fake Google Street View Auto. Das war im Prinzip ja noch bevor es sozusagen richtig losbrannte in Deutschland. Da gab es schon so die ersten Stimmen.
Du hast zu der hitzigen Debatte quasi schon vorweg gegriffen.
Aber danach ist ja dann noch da reine Wahnsinn losgebrochen.
Also ihr habt ein Google... Was ist das hier? So ein Ford Fiesta?
Ja, das ist so ein Ford Modell. Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Und das haben auch genau die... Also solche Autos wurden auch von Google verwendet.
Ja, genau. Die beiden Bilder, die du da hast, das ist einmal oben das Original.
Ach so, das ist das Original.
2009 durch die Gegend gefahren ist und da drunter, das haben wir gebaut. Und ich habe einfach den Mietwagen, den haben wir bei Europcar oder ich weiß nicht wo geholt.
Und dann habt ihr da so eine Attrappe oben drauf gebaut.
Genau, Kammerattrappe und Google-Schild an die Seite geklebt an die Tür. Und da war kein Kabel dran und nichts. Das war alles Plastik und Pappe. Und wenn man sich das angeguckt hat, hat man das auch gesehen. Aber es guckt halt keiner genau hin, weil alle wissen, das ist das Google-Auto. Und die stehen neben dir am Fenster und reden mit dir und glauben es halt.
Und was habt ihr dann gemacht?
Wir sind halt durch die Stadt gefahren, einen Tag lang. Und haben im Prinzip Unfug mit dem Auto angestellt. Es war auch so ein bisschen so eine Gradwanderung. Jetzt lasst uns nicht Werbung machen für Google. Diese ganze Aktion war auch Teil. Das Fat Lab hat sich da getroffen. Und bei der Transmediate, wir haben dann in Honorable Mansion gewonnen, tralala, und haben die Fuck-Google-Week veranstaltet. Eine Themenwoche, wo es allerlei so Browser-Addons und verschiedene kleine Programmchen und Spielchen zu Google gab. Diese ganze Diskussion. Man kann so eine Fuck-Week zu allem machen, auch zu Facebook oder zu Apple oder überall. Es gibt Themen, die gerne beleuchtet werden wollen. Hier war das Google-Auto ein Teil von dieser Woche. Wir sind damit herumgefahren und da gibt es ein schönes Video, wo der Fahrer auf dem Google-Auto trinkt aus der Whiskey-Flasche. Oder der Beifahrer klappt, der James steigt aus und pinkelt beim Adlon irgendwo an einem Baum. Wir haben gestellte Szenen, ein Unfall mit einem Fahrradfahrer oder direkt am Kotti auf dem Kreisel bleibt das Auto stehen und es gibt eine technische Panne. Der Fahrer steigt aus und telefoniert. Es gibt so lauter so eine Aneinanderreihung von kleinen Vorkommnissen.
Und haben die Leute dann irgendwie reagiert?
Ja, das ist schon extrem gewesen. Ich habe vorhin auch mit Freunden diskutiert, dass keiner das Auto kennt. Da kannten es dann doch schon ziemlich viele. Und es haben natürlich alle gewinkt. Ich bin den ganzen Tag das gefahren. Das war fast unheimlich. Du kannst mit 20 fahren durch die Stadt und hinter dir fünf Taxis haben, aber keiner hupt. Du bist das Google-Auto. In Kreuzburg sind wir ganz langsam gefahren an der Oranienstraße. Oranienburger? Nee, Oranienstraße. Und da gibt es in dem Video auch so ein paar Jungs, die Hosen runterlassen und so. Was dann nicht wir waren, sozusagen. Aber da gab es auch den Finger und alles. Und dann haben wir immer so halb gespielt. Das Fetlab-Auto hat nämlich das Google-Auto verfolgt. Es gab einen Tweet an dem Tag, wo wir dann behauptet haben, wir haben das getaggt mit einem GPS-Gerät und verfolgen das jetzt in der Stadt. Und dann ist in diesem Video auch immer der rote Golf, der das verfolgt und de facto auch angreift. Also am Ende dann den Google-Fahrer aus dem Auto zerrt und das Google-Auto entführt und so. Wo dann auch wieder jemand eingreift von der Straße tatsächlich. Das war schon erstaunlich. Und ja, war sehr spaßig. Also am Ende, das musste natürlich auch noch passieren, fährt dann so eine Einfahrt und das kracht oben die Kamera runter natürlich, weil die Einfahrt nicht hoch genug ist und so. Hat das jemand gesehen? Dummspielen, ja, nee, vor Ort. Das war irgendwie dann schon am Abend und so. Das haben nicht viele da gesehen. Aber einfach diese Tatsache, dass alle das glauben und auch sofort man also Gespräche am Fenster hat. Ach genau, ein schönes Ding auf der Google-Streetview-Fahrer fragt nach dem Weg, eine Karte aneignet. Ich hab mich dann gestellt irgendwo auf Wilhelmstraße und dachte, wie komme ich nach München, wie komme ich denn nach München? Und es ging natürlich darum, das so, ja, möglichst so aussehen zu lassen, dass es nicht halt, ja, am Ende für Google toll aussieht. Vor der chinesischen Botschaft haben wir uns eine Weile hingestellt. Da war gerade diese Diskussion total im Gange mit China. Da haben wir schöne Fotografien abgegriffen.
Aber die haben sich da nicht zu irgendeiner Reaktion?
Die haben sich nicht gemeldet. Es gab, also, naja, so ein bisschen die Side-Story war, dass die Transmediale auch mitgesponsert war von Google, weil die da ein, zwei Arbeiten hatten, die auch sozusagen von Google, wo Leute mitgeholfen haben, was zu programmieren. Und die PR-Abteilung hatte irgendwie ein Problem mit dem Namen, mit dem Titel der Arbeit und also mit diesem ganzen Fakt Google. Und haben aber nicht interveniert, weil sie auch selbst einen Katalogtext durchgelesen, den wir geschrieben haben. Es ist immer so provokant, aber dann steht ja noch sozusagen diese ganze Debatte dahinter. Und die sind natürlich auch nicht doof, weil in dem Moment, wo sie intervenieren würden, dann würde das Ding ja noch viel mehr abgehen. Klar, zu dreilang. Also insofern machen sie das nicht. Und es war nur spannend im Nachhinein, es gibt so ein schönes Foto auf der CeBIT-Messe, da haben sie ja noch versucht, eine Dickwerbung zu machen für Street View, und dann hatten sie so Künstler aus Miami da, die dann irgendwie die Autos, die Google Autos so besprüht haben, ganz bunt und so. Und man echt nachher dachte wieder so, ja, das sieht eigentlich fast nach Fetlab aus ungefähr. Also es war ganz witzig, was da auf eine Art Reaktion dann noch gekommen ist, aber konkret direkt dann auch nicht.
Du hattest ja noch so eine ganz persönliche Begegnung.
Ja genau, die persönliche Begegnung, das ist das Witzige eigentlich, das war dann das Jahr davor, als das echte Google Auto noch umgefahren ist in Berlin. Ich sitze morgens immer gerne im Café Murda an der Bausigstraße und da fuhr der mal lang im Oktober 2009. Und ich bin halt auch rausgesprungen, so irgendwie klar, ah hier, das ist er. Und jetzt, da musst du natürlich mit drauf und bin irgendwie die ganze Straße mit diesem Auto hinterher gerannt, auch sozusagen mit dieser Fragestellung. Ja, bleibt man drauf, die nehmen ja auch immer gerne Sachen raus. Also alles, was so zu, wenn irgendwo einer, weiß ich nicht, die schlimmen Sachen passieren muss. Also das haben sie ja auch dann immer, das löschen sie einmal gerne. Und ich bin jetzt auf, weiß nicht, acht, neun, zehn so Frames drauf, wie ich hinter diesem Auto herlaufe. Und als wir hier in Deutschland dann die Veröffentlichung hatten, letzten Jahres im Herbst, dann stand auch ein Tagesspiegel vorne, ja, wütender Mann läuft dem Auto hinterher. Wenn man sich das anguckt, ich tanze eigentlich hinter dem Auto oder man läuft erst mal so 20 Meter, reißt die Arme hoch dabei, weil ich will sozusagen irgendwann, ich weiß ja nicht, wann man das Foto macht, aber man muss sozusagen in verschiedene Posen draufkommen. Und das gibt es dann sozusagen als eine, ich nenne das jetzt eine Selbstportrait-Reihe, die ich dann auch wieder in dem Café ausgestellt habe, wo ich sozusagen gesessen habe, als das Auto vorbei fuhr. Das haben immer alle nicht geglaubt so ungefähr, das ist doch Photoshop und so. Und ja, genau, wie wir die Welt sozusagen wahrnehmen. Beziehungsweise die Arbeit heißt ja auch 15 Seconds of Fame. Also die, ja, man ist dann berühmte.
So, ein anderes Opfer von dir ist World of Warcraft.
Spielst du das eigentlich? Nee, ich habe das nie wirklich gespielt. Also es gab, ja bei ein paar Arbeiten auch das letzte Spiel, was ich wirklich richtig gespielt habe, und das war auch schon lange her, das war eigentlich Counter-Strike und Half-Life und so ein Kram. Das ist aber eben ja auch schon die zehn Jahre her mindestens. Aber ich habe mich, also ja, ich bin natürlich auch irgendwie mit Computern aufgewachsen und Games und habe mir das immer viel und lange noch angeguckt, auch wenn ich selber nicht mehr gespielt habe. WoW ist ja klar, das war ja so ein Ding, da entweder man macht das sozusagen volle Kante oder man lässt da lieber die Finger von so ungefähr. Aber die Arbeit ist im Prinzip ja auch in der, weiß nicht, 2003, 2004, 2005 oder wenn das schon besteht. Was steht da für ein Datum?
2006 bis 2009, aber ich...
Ja genau, weil das immer wieder sozusagen aufgeführt wurde. Aber oben ist dieser Screenshot von der Gruppe, die da vor dem, wo ein Monster steht, was sie sozusagen gerade gekillt haben. Und dazu erzähle ich immer gerne, also auch vor allen Dingen dieser ganzen Gruppe, die diese Spiele gar nicht kennen und die MMOs nicht kennen und wie viel Zeit da, die Leute, die sich in die Ohren schlagen und auch sich gut kennenlernen. Und dass das Ganze sozusagen sozial so eine Wichtigkeit auch erlangt für die Person, die das spielen und eben auch wieder einen sehr großen Teil deiner Realität einnehmen kann, wenn du dich da viel rumtreibst. Und die machen dann ein Erinnerungsfoto, weil sie gerade den Endgegner da in dem Quest irgendwie gekillt haben. Und das ist so ein Erinnerungsfoto, wie wenn wir so eine Reise machen oder so, weil es einfach ein wichtiger Moment ist. Der Drache wird dann zum Eiffelturm. Und da sozusagen darüber nachzudenken, über dieses, was machen wir hier und da und wie ähnlich ist das eigentlich und was bedeutet das. Weil wenn man die Sachen nicht kennt, dann ach ja, das ist so ein buntes Spiel, das sieht so kindermäßig aus und so. Die einen nehmen es halt immer nicht ernst und wir die anderen, das ist halt total ernst. Oder wichtig. Und da geht es dann um die, das ist aber eigentlich dann auch wieder was, was an jedem 3D-Spiel eigentlich fast vorkommt. Es ist eher so eine Interface-Geschichte wie dieser Map-Marker auch, dass dann über jedem, über dem Avatar, über dem Spielerkopf dann der Name schwebt. Und wenn man das spielt, dann guckt man das ja auch. Das ist ja fast auch, glaube ich, programmiertechnisch ein 2D-Objekt. Das ist ja nicht mal 3D sozusagen. Und da dann diese, in der Arbeit, also das ist immer ein Workshop, mache ich mit einer Gruppe, wo dann bauen wir unsere echten Namen aus Pappe und werden die auf so einem Plastikstreifen aufgeklebt, der dann auch, weiß ich mal, so richtig groß ist, also einen Meter breit oder 1,50. Und an so einer Angel laufen wir dann unsere Namen in der Stadt im öffentlichen Raum so, als wenn wir in einem Computerspiel wären. Oder neben dem Prinzip dieses...
Auch so mit dem Original-Fond.
Mit dem Original-Fond und der Farbe aus WoW jetzt. Das hat hier auch so, wie bei diesen Google-Projekten, einen Google-Bezug, ein World of Warcraft-Bezug, aber also jedes andere Spiel, das man aufmacht, da sieht es dann ähnlich aus. Insofern ist das dann wieder übertragbar auf andere Spiele auch, aber in dem Fall WoW-bezogen. Und dann immer diese Frage, ist das auch ein MMO? Ja, die Welt ist ja eigentlich auch, oder?
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall sehr massiv, viel Multi.
Ich habe also, es gibt genau dieses Ganze, wenn man sich viel rumtreibt, oder auch von Leuten, die Sims gespielt haben, früher viel, wo dann immer, Herr, mein Zufriedenbalken ist gerade auf drei Viertel. Also wenn man dann diese Dinge so annimmt, oder wenn man viel Counter-Strike gespielt hat, dann kommt man nach Hause und springt um die Ecke, weil da ist doch jetzt gleich einer. Also man so stark noch unter Schock steht. Und dann kommt aber natürlich, wenn man diese Aktion in der Stadt macht und mit seinen eigenen Namen rumläuft, noch diese ganze Privacy-Debatte dazu, die ich dann interessant finde, weil sich ja vor allen Dingen im letzten Jahrzehnt sich so viel getan hat. Also meinen Klarnamen habe ich ja vor zehn Jahren nicht irgendwo im Internet gelassen. Heute, wenn man mit seinem Klarnamen nicht zu finden ist, dann ist das ja eher suspekt. Und die, du bist nicht auf Facebook, ist auch komisch, komisch. Und wie wäre das denn, wenn wir mit unserem Namen in der Stadt rumlaufen? Also ich habe jetzt gerade wieder in New York gesehen, da ist ja das immer alles noch auf einer Stufe weiter, vor allen Dingen mit so Datingdiensten über das Location-Base. Und dass du dann genau gucken kannst, wer alles den und den Datingdienst benutzt, der in derselben Bar ist und so. Das sind ja diese Ideen, die gibt es ja schon so lange. Ich habe mir das auch immer angeguckt. Und das kommt immer mehr. Und im Endeffekt kommt es so ein bisschen drauf an. In manchen Ländern, in den USA, sagst du ja ziemlich schnell deinen Namen. Man kann sich schon noch real kennenlernen und auch nach einem Namen fragen. Auf einer Konferenz laufen wir mit diesen Namentexten herum. Diese richtigen Web 2.0-Konferenzen. Ich habe damals die Reboot, wo ich das gecheckt habe. Die hatten riesige Namentexte, wo schon klar war, du kannst also noch aus 5 Metern Entfernung den Namen lesen und musst dich nicht so vorbeugen.
Das ist dann schon fast wie bei deiner Installation.
Ja, es geht dann in diese Richtung. Und das hat sich natürlich Privatsphäre ganz stark wandelt und geändert. Aber was ich auf der Straße mache, das ist eine ganz alte Regel. Man stellt sich nicht an die Ecke und zieht sich nackt aus. Das machst du eigentlich nicht. Das sind ja Konventionen, die sind ja über Jahrhunderte gewachsen. Da ändert sich auch nicht so schnell was dran. Aber ja, kommt jetzt sozusagen, ist die Frage halt. Kann ich noch an der Bar jemand ansprechen? Oder kann ich das eigentlich nur noch mit dem Dating-Dienst sozusagen? Wenn ich dir vorher das Profil gecheckt habe. Da haben wir letztendlich noch drüber lustig gemacht. Aber bei solchen Arbeiten ist diese ganze Frage auch da noch so, liegt da noch mit drin.
Ja, das könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen. Es gibt ja auch schon immer wieder solche spielerischen Digital-Visitenkarten-Projekte mit RFID etc. Man stellt sich jetzt vor, man hat halt im Konferenz-Batch nicht nur seinen Namen draufgeschrieben, sondern ist quasi auch sofort peer-to-peer-mäßig so scannbar und erfassbar. Dann hast du auch gleich wieder diese Post-Privacy-Diskussion, die ja derzeit akut grassiert. So mit so, oh Gott, wie kannst du nur? Auf der einen Seite, und jetzt kannst du getrickt werden. Und wenn man das alles kombiniert, dann weißt du gleich, mit wem du dich unterhält und so. Und die andere Seite so, ja, ist doch super, oder? Wo sich das irgendwie so ein bisschen aufspaltet, wo man auch nicht so richtig sagen kann, wohin die Reise geht, oder ob das eine oder das andere sich da jetzt durchsetzt oder co-existieren wird, oder wie auch immer.
Und hier, das ist eben sozusagen das, was ich daran mag, auch dass es sichtbar wird dadurch. Also die nächste Stufe von dieser über dem Kopf schweben, sozusagen einmal, wann sie den Namen, und dann gibt es diese Chat-Geschichte mit den Sprechblasen. Damit war ich ja auch im Kongress. Genau, damit war ich ja auch im Kongress. Und auf vielen Veranstaltungen, wo man sozusagen im Prinzip, als Benutzer hast du ein Keyboard, du hast das Keyboard umgehängt und kannst da reintippen und über dir schwebt so eine Sprechblase, die dann auch jemand trägt. Dann hast du ein kleiner Projekt da hinten dran. Und dann wird das direkt sozusagen angezeigt, was du geschrieben hast. Und auch wieder dieser Unterschied. Also ich kann mich irgendwann im IRC-Chat sozusagen einklinken und bin einer von vielen und mehr oder weniger anonym. Und dann reden die Leute sozusagen auch dementsprechend. Und wenn ich aber dann da stehe und alle sehen, dass ich das jetzt gerade sage tatsächlich, und auch das Schrift ja auch wieder oder dann das geschriebene Wort, ja, dafür ist man ja nochmal anders haftbar als ein Gespräch, was man so vielleicht mithört im Café. Aber wie wäre das, wenn wir alle so Sprechblasen haben? Beziehungsweise sind ja, weiß ich nicht, hier unsere Logs auf diesen mobilen Geräten sind ja sozusagen schon unsere Sprechblasen. Man kann das eben alles immer nicht sehen. Gerade gestern, diese Breitband-Sendung gehört, die letzte von gestern, wo auch die Junior-Professorin aus Hamburg die Wahrnehmung darüber, wie ich sozusagen die Leute auf Facebook und diesen Social Networks kommunizieren, ist eine sehr private Wahrnehmung. Weil man sitzt eben alleine zu Hause am Rechner und ich chatte jetzt, ich rede zu meinen Freunden oder so. Und das fühlt sich so heimlich an, sozusagen. Heimisch, keine Ahnung, also recht privat. Genau, dieses Unter-Sicht-Gefühl ist viel stärker. Und im Endeffekt wissen wir alle, dass das natürlich das absolute Gegenteil ist.
Sie baden gerade ihre Hände da drin, sage ich nur. Wir führen hier so ein ganz intimes Gespräch, aber irgendwie so wenn ich alleine. Was hier ist es anders?
Naja, ich weiß gar nicht. Man ist natürlich nicht live oder so, aber man weiß dann schon, dass das noch einige Leute hören werden.
Aber beim Chat nicht so, obwohl es alles viel einfacher speichermal ist. Second Live ist hier auch so ein Bild bei deinem Doku von deinem Chat.
Ja genau, im Second Live habe ich auch ein paar Arbeiten. Oder über mit Second Live gemacht, damals 2007, als das irgendwie so sehr präsent war.
Halbzehnte.
Das lässt sich auch so gut erklären. Das war natürlich so ein schöner Presseliebling. Ja genau, es ist diese Chat-Geschichte, da gibt es so ein Beispielbild von Second Live, aber auch von World of Warcraft. Ich finde es auch spannend, einfach chatten ist ja was, was ja auch nicht verschwunden ist, obwohl wir alle Voice-over-IP können heute und alles Mögliche andere, aber dieses ganze Echtzeit-Text kommunizieren ist einfach so eine Zwischenkommunikationsform, die eine sehr eigene Wertigkeit hat, also ein enger Kanal, über den man nicht so viel sagen kann schnell, aber oft sagen die Leute dann gewichtige Sachen. Wenn man dann miteinander redet, dann ist es plötzlich ganz anders. Ich meine, ihr kennt das alle. Ich finde es sehr spannend, wie sich das etabliert als ein eigener Kommunikationskanal. Und in diesen 3D-Spielen ist dann der Chat wieder, wo es heute Voice-over-IP schon längst gibt überall. Aber gerade bei diesen Spielen, viele Spieler oder eine bestimmte Gruppe immer sagt, ich will eigentlich chatten, weil dann das ganze Game nicht durch die Stimme gebrochen wird. Also dieser virtuelle Raum und die Fantasie, die da drum entsteht. Wenn du dann sozusagen die querkigen Stimmen über den Kanal hörst, von irgendeinem tollen Elf oder was auch immer, Ork, das dann der 12-Jährige ist aus den USA, dann reagiert es sozusagen, kann das sein, dass einem da die Fantasie einverlässt. Nichtsdestotrotz, bei irgendwelchen strategischen Sachen wird natürlich gechattet, weil das natürlich echtzeitmäßig viel praktischer ist. Und die Sprechblase kennen wir natürlich wieder vom Comic. Insofern schwebt in den 3D-Spielen das Gechattete über den Kopf der Person. Und das ist aber auch aus mehreren Spielen oder verschiedensten Arten von Spielen übertragbar. Und Second Life ließ sich einfach so wahnsinnig gut erklären, weil das ist genau wie mit dieser Google-Geschichte. Das Auto, das durchs Land fährt und jedes Haus und jeden Garten fotografiert, das verstehen alle, was so ein Cookie ist und wie Daten erhoben werden oder so. Da haben die Journalisten gar keine Lust, das zu erklären, weil das so dröge und trocken ist und so. Und Second Life ist dann halt diese Welt gewesen, wo dann die Welt wird noch mal gebaut, beziehungsweise kann man sich da alles machen und bauen, was man will. Und es gibt diese schönen Bilder von den Menschen, die da rumlaufen. Das lässt sich auch super kommunizieren, im Gegensatz zu, wie damals das anfing mit Twitter. Was ist Twitter? Das war ja immer so.
Hast du denn Zeit verbracht mit Second Life?
Ich habe da auch Zeit verbracht.
Es ist ja auch immer noch der Ort, wo das Reale und das Virtuelle extrem nah zusammenkommen.
Das Problem ist, glaube ich, der Punkt. Es bleibt schon immer der Punkt, warum es nicht wirklich am Ende funktioniert oder nicht auf die Art und Weise. Grundsätzlich glaube ich eher, dass das Digitale zu uns kommt. Also diese Augmented-Geschichte, genauso wie bei mir vor dem Tisch jetzt ein Smartphone liegt, eine WIFAR-Bedienung und so ein Tablet hier. Dass man sozusagen diese Erweiterung der Körpergeschichte hat. Das ist ja die ganz klassische Vorstellung von Virtualität. Da ist dieser Cyberraum so, da kann ich mich mit meinem Avatar durchbewegen. Hey, ich kann sogar fliegen. Und eigentlich warbe ich nur noch in so einem Becken rum. Also so matrixmäßig bin ich angeschlossen. So wird das eben nicht kommen oder vielleicht nicht so schnell. Also geht eher darum, dass das Wir, wie Wir sozusagen, Augmented ist ja auch immer so ein Zauberwort, aber es passiert eher auf der Ebene, wie es sozusagen im realen Traum den Einzug erhält durch verschiedenste Art und Weisen von Tools. Und Second Life war so sehr die Bühne, also die Leute sind halt da reingegangen, um eben nicht sie selbst zu sein, wie auf Facebook, was ja eigentlich sozusagen viel erfolgreicher als alles andere ist, weil da geht es sozusagen um die Realität ganz hautnah. Und Second Life war einfach die Bühne und das Theater spielen und das verkleiden und dann auch da seine Träume und Fantasien ausleben und dieses Ganze halt. Also das ist eher so ein schöner Spiegel für die Gesellschaft, weil die Leute dann da die Sachen gemacht haben, die sie gerne machen wollen, bzw. schön aussehen, ein Haus bauen, ein dickes Auto haben. So, ja, die einfachen Sachen. Party machen und die ganze Zeit tanzen. Die spannenden Ecken fand ich eigentlich in Second Life so. Es gab diese Sandboxen, wo jeder einfach bauen konnte und machen konnte, was er wollte. Und das waren eigentlich so sehr surreale Ecken, wo dann absurdes Zeug passiert ist. Was viel interessanter war als eine Wohnsiedlung oder so. Aber ja, da hat das... Ich habe verschiedene Spiele und verschiedene, sozusagen, Welten beleucht. Ich fand es damals schon interessant, weil es eben in dem Sinne kein Spiel war. Also im Endeffekt ist das irgendwie auch eine Art Spiel. Aber da haben sich auch viele drüber gestritten. Aber weil es noch mal einen anderen Freiheitsgrad hatte. Und genau, aber eigentlich ist es auch ein bisschen wie so eine Phase. Also diese verschiedenen Objekten aus Games, also aus Counter-Strike, gibt es ja diese Kisten oder eine Brille mit der AK am Anschlag und verschiedene Sachen. Das war... Das mache ich jetzt auch noch teilweise, aber anders. Ich habe mich dann eher um Web-Sachen gekümmert oder Google-Kram gekümmert. Also eher so ein anderes Feld. Und bei den Games-Sachen, das haben wir vorhin auch schon gesagt, es gibt dann wie so eine ganze Welle. Also man findet auf YouTube tonnenweise Videos, wo Leute Super Mario nachspielen auf ihrem Campus an der Uni mit Kisten in der Hand. Das war wie so eine kulturelle Welle auch, weil... Ich glaube, so hat es bei mir selber auch angefangen. Dieses ganze... Guck mal, also einmal hat es damit angefangen, man macht 1000 Projekte, macht Sachen irgendwie aus in 3D und dann stellst du fest, nach drei Jahren, CD-ROM geht nicht mehr, ist eigentlich weg, das Projekt jetzt sozusagen. Hast du irgendwie so und so viel, also dieses ganze Datenverlust, Laptop geklaut und sowieso, wo man feststellt, hey, ich verbringe so viel Zeit und wo ist es eigentlich? Und jetzt ist es weg und es ist ja so ephemer und virtuell bzw. flüchtig. Und gleichzeitig dann dieser, ich will es auch wieder anfassen können. Und warum, back to the roots. Genau, warum hat das nicht sozusagen einen realen Bezug irgendwie hier zu dem Leben auf der Straße. Und so ist das im Prinzip entstanden aus diesem Gefühl heraus. Und das hat glaube ich auch ziemlich viele, das ist wie so ein kulturelles Ding, wo dann die Gamer haben viel so Zeug gemacht. Es gibt irgendwie gerade, ich weiß nicht, bei Counter-Strike habe ich mir früher so Sachen angeschaut, wo dann die Levels nachgebaut haben in Sand am Strand, im Baggersee, weil sie den Level einfach auswendig können, weil du den auswendig können musst.
Counter-Strike-Level haben als Sandbogen.
Ja, weil das halt, ich finde es total spannend. Also da bin ich gerade auch noch mal dran, dieses Ganze wie Architektur und so.
Wie groß sind denn diese Level so?
Ja, in Counter-Strike waren die ja eigentlich recht klein.
Immer so Compounds mit oben und unten.
Ja, genau, so ein bisschen überschaubar. Also im Vergleich mit irgendeinem MMO, wo es massig Landschaft gibt. Es war sozusagen begrenzt. Und dann diese Truppen, die aufeinandertreffen.
Das kriegt man noch gebaut bis zur nächsten Flut.
Und dass du, ja, wie sehr das eigentlich so ein, weiß ich, bei Filmen oder bei Büchern kann man über Szenen reden oder über Atmosphären oder wir können uns über Blade Runner unterhalten und so wie so. Und bei so Spielen, wenn du das mal gespielt hast, und ob das so nämlich auch die ganze Früh, diese Doom und Duke Nukem, was man früher so gespielt hat, wenn du dich da ransetzt jetzt, die Leute kennen das. Du hast das, also weil wir wachsen natürlich, das ist ja Teil unserer evolutionären Fähigkeit, sozusagen, den dreidimensionellen Raum irgendwie. Ich war mal hier bei dir im Studio schon mal, ich hab es auch so wiedergefunden, weil ich die Straße kenne und den Ort kenne und es stand zwar ein Gerüst vor der Tür, ein bisschen irritiert, aber wir sind 3D sozusagen gebildet und insofern, wenn man dann in so einem Level über und über Stunden darin verbracht hatte, musste er jede Ecke und jeden Winkel kennen, um das Spiel spielen zu können, auch um zu überleben und wie das sozusagen die Architektur selber so ein wichtiges Element wird irgendwie. Und ja, es ist sozusagen virtuell und künstlich, aber eigentlich vielleicht viel realer als, ich weiß nicht, so eine Stadt wie Dubai oder so, die ja auch sozusagen aus dem Boden gestampft wird und eigentlich auch nur noch gerendert aussieht. Es gibt so ein schönes Haus am Potsdamer Platz, das eigentlich gar kein Haus ist, da ist ja sozusagen mehr oder weniger fertig gebaut jetzt, aber es gibt dieses eine Ding, wo man dann mal, also überall werden ja mal Folien aufgespannt oder Werbung draufgeknallt, dahinter ist Baustelle.
Potemkinche Dörfer.
Genau, und da war immer so, ja, ja, Baustelle. Irgendwann so checkst du, das ist Teil von diesem Leipziger Platz, von diesem Achteck, die Ecke zum Potsdamer Platz direkt, wo man denkt, irgendwann gecheckt, da ist gar keine Baustelle hinter. Das ist einfach, das ist nur das Gerüst für diese Folie. Und dann ist da ein Haus drauf gerendert sozusagen, ja, wie die anderen Häuser am Potsdamer Platz auch aussehen, so schöne Lochfassade, Stein, Krams. Und dann wird die Werbung sozusagen auf die Folie noch mit draufgenommen. Und die ist nicht mal da drauf, sondern das ist sozusagen, das ist alles eine Folie. Aber die hat noch so ein Dropshadow, als wenn sie da drangehängt ist. Also, ja, ich hab das, ich mach dann immer Fotos von solchen Situationen, denke immer so, okay, warte mal so, wo bin ich jetzt?
Was es jetzt hier eigentlich war.
Das ist doch hier eine Textur und das ist doch gerendert. Also so, und das ist mal das Spannende, diese Momente, wo man irgendwie Apfel-Z drücken will, weil man die U-Bahn-Station verpasst hat. Oder so, erwarte mal, ach nee, geht nicht.
Stimmt, dieser Mangel an Einfluss, den man hat auf schwere Objekte.
Genau, wo man merkt, ach nein, jetzt ist mir irgendwie, ich hab mal an einem Stein rumgekloppt, auch wenn der ein Stück abbricht. Das ist ab halt. Also so ganz fundamentale Sachen. Auch spannend bei diesen analogen Screens, wir haben über Papierpixel geredet, aber Random-Screen ist so ein Screen, der über Teelichter, der mit Teelichtern läuft und es sind so 5x5 Pixel und jedes Pixel ist im Prinzip, vorne blinkt es einfach random und hinten guckt man dann rein und sieht, dass jedes Pixel ist so eine Box mit einem Teelicht, wo sich so eine Dose drauf dreht und das Licht dann freigibt nach vorne durch ein Fenster und durch die aufsteigende Wärme dreht sich diese Dose und als ich das gebaut hab, ne rumexperimentiere, mich auch kindisch gefreut und so und dann aber vergessen, irgendwie ein paar Kerzen auszumachen, bin nach Hause gegangen und das war das ganze Atelier abgebrannt, weil dann antierst du plötzlich mit Feuer. Also redet immer so über einen digitalen Raum und so und dann kommt man zu den elementaren Dingen und das Ding ist dann abgebrannt, aber es war noch zum Glück jemand da im Nachbarraum, hat das dann irgendwie gelöscht. Mit einem Eimer Wasser, ja. Also, ja, in diesen Momenten so, oh ja, das ist jetzt sozusagen wirklich, wirklich kalt, ja.
Was denkst du denn so, ich meine, es gibt ja immer so diese Diskussion, ich habe es vorhin schon so ein bisschen angesprochen, so, ne, gerade mit den Spielen, aber auch Online-Sucht. Was es sicherlich gibt, ja, ich will das gar nicht in Abrede stellen. Also es gibt Zweifel, Zweifel ohne, gibt es wie in allem einzelne, vielleicht auch schon mehrere, die wirklich so krankhaft sich in die Auseinandersetzung mit Dingen hineinfallen lassen. Und selbstverständlich gibt es das auch mit allem, was mit Computern spielen, im Besonderen aber auch nicht nur und Netz etc. zu tun hat. Aber ich denke, das ist halt eher so eine, da reden wir ja über spezielle Krankheitsbilder, die sich dann darin manifestieren, dass man eben das tut. Aber es kann, also ich empfinde das zumindest nicht so, dass es jetzt irgendwelche Qualitäten gibt online oder so, die jetzt noch mehr als Ursache dessen begründen können. Also ich habe nicht so den Eindruck, dass das Netz tut sich auf, dann kommt ja so ein Hai raus und reißt einem den Kopf ab. Weil das jetzt so besonders gefährlich ist, sondern das hat halt immer was mit einem selbst zu tun. Trotzdem, wie du schon ja jetzt viele Beispiele gegeben hast, diese permanente Auseinandersetzung mit Netzdingen, mit diesem Ando machen können, dieses ganze permanente Erleben der Vernetzung und Kommunikation mit den anderen, das hat ja auch Wechselwirkungen. Weil wir gehen dann immer mit diesem Fragezeichen durch unseren realen Raum und versuchen das halt irgendwie zu adaptieren. Das habe ich hier so die Piratenpartei, auch so beseelt mit diesem, aber das funktioniert doch da so toll. Das muss sich doch jetzt auch auf die Realität anwenden lassen. Wir brauchen irgendwie Online-Meinungsbildung und all das. Und jetzt ist unser Server mal ausgeschaltet gewesen. Wir waren gelähmt. Wir konnten ja gar nicht mehr arbeiten. Auch eine interessante Darstellung der Situation. Da geht ja mal der Strom aus und dann kann irgendwie die Partei nicht mehr arbeiten. Trotzdem steckt da natürlich auch mehr drin als nur als ein Wunsch. Ich denke, es ist bei vielen eben auch schon so eine tiefe Erkenntnis, dass da was drin steckt, dass da was gehen muss. Auch wenn es auf viele, viele Widerstände und Zweifel stößt.
Ja, ich meine, das hat er wahrscheinlich. Also einmal ist da dieses grundsätzliche Ding, steckt natürlich immer drin der Technologieglaube und auch gerade beim Internet und den Wurzeln des Internets dieses Es macht alles besser, ja, also diese Grundidee jetzt, das macht die Welt demokratisch oder hilft ganz vielen Menschen und so.
Jeder ist ein Sender.
Laptop-Vertschalt-Kram und dieser ganzen. Das sind natürlich, wie man jetzt sozusagen gesehen hat, an arabischen Revolutionen und dem Kram, hat das natürlich Auswirkungen auf jeden Fall. Aber ja, es funktioniert nicht von alleine. Es macht es nicht per se sozusagen. Die Gesellschaft profitiert nicht einfach nur davon, weil das jetzt da ist, sondern es geht natürlich immer um den Umgang damit oder wie man das benutzt. Und es gibt ja auch immer natürlich die wichtigen kritischen Gegenstimmen, dass wir können jetzt alle sozusagen ganz toll, ganz schnell eine Demo organisieren ad hoc oder so. Aber die Gegenseite kann das natürlich alles noch viel besser überwachen. Also diese ganze Diskussion. Und es funktioniert nicht, es ist sehr hilfreich, aber es funktioniert nicht von alleine. Und ich finde auch schon dieses Ganze dieser Technologie glaube ich, also per se ist ja, wenn irgendwo was Neues erfunden wird, dann in der Wissenschaft wird ja oft auch so gearbeitet, dass sie irgendwie wieder irgendwelche Mikro-Materiellen untersuchen, aber eigentlich noch nicht genau wissen, wofür das angewendet werden kann. Und dann wird dann sozusagen in der Medienkunst auch oft gerne dann erst mal, ach, hier gibt es was Neues, lass mal da was damit machen.
Grundlagenforschung.
Ja, genau. Und dann, ach, wofür können wir es benutzen, ach, machen wir so ein Kunstwerk draus. Und ich finde das immer schade, oder man muss sich schon, klar sollte man sich natürlich immer erst angucken, was man eigentlich will und dann wofür man es benutzt, also ob es jetzt, oder wie man dahin kommt. Und bei diesen gesellschaftlichen Sachen oder auch jetzt mit der Abhängigkeit. Man sieht das immer, du hast ja auch Kinder, ich habe selber auch zwei Kinder. Und da sieht man es immer am besten auch. Also klar, da kommt kein High raus aus dem Bildschirm, aber also sozusagen das, was mit Computerspielen anfängt, oder überhaupt sozusagen dieser bunte Bildschirm, das kann ja auch schon Fernsehen sein bei Kleinen, das erregt einfach, also das zieht einfach Aufmerksamkeit auf sich extrem. Später für uns, man ist ja sozusagen schon medial geprägt und gereift und, ich weiß nicht, ausgebildet. Aber bei mir ist das sozusagen meine eigene Diskussion immer mit, gucke ich jetzt meine E-Mails nach oder nicht? Oder auch, wenn ich da sozusagen diese Hassliebe so, es könnte was Interessantes im E-Mail-Inbox sein, sind meistens da immer Sachen drin, die in Arbeit sozusagen weitergehen. Sprich, man muss antworten oder irgendwas anderes machen. Beziehungsweise ja, dann gucke ich heute mal nicht nach. Also ich weiß selber auch genau so sehr da drum, wie schwer mir das fällt, sozusagen das nicht zu tun und man dann auch immer weiß, ich habe das ganze Wochenende keine E-Mails nachgeguckt. Das ist ja sozusagen voller Wahnsinn. Aber ja, dieses Spiel damit und auch die Medienkompetenz heißt das ja. Also wie wir mit bestimmten Sachen sozusagen umgehen, lernen oder auch dieses Ganze, wie viel man was tut und ab welchem Punkt es eigentlich keinen Sinn mehr macht. Also ich auch gerne diese viele diese Arbeiten auch, wo ich dann versuche, irgendwelche digitalen Prozesse auf so etwas Low-Taggiges runterzubrechen. Man kann sich noch sozusagen komplizierte Sachen ausdenken. Manchmal kannst du auch einen Stift und Zettel das aufschreiben und dem an die Wand hängen oder so. Oder sozusagen als Nachricht jemand auf dem Tisch legen oder so. Also was, gibt ja immer noch die ganz einfachen Dinge. Und die Kombination aus denen dann sozusagen, man nimmt was sozusagen altes oder was ganz fundamental Normales und kombiniert das mit irgendeiner neuen Technologie und so. Das finde ich dann immer eher spannend, das sozusagen zu minimalisieren und solche Sachen.
Ja, gerade so diese Kommunikation. Gibt ja hier auch so ein ganz aktuelles Ding. Ich muss zunehmen, dass ich mich bisher nur am Rande ein bisschen damit beschäftigt habe. Aber das scheint ja auch eingeschlagen zu haben wie eine Bombe. Diese Sache mit diesen OSB-Sticks.
Ach so, ja. Die Dead Drops. Was ist das? Das habe ich im Oktober in New York angefangen. Da hatte ich so eine Art of Residence bei iBeam. Klassischerweise ist das der tote Briefkasten aus dem Kalten Krieg. Also der Ort, an dem da ein Informant was hinterlässt und der andere das dann später abholt.
So ein Schlitz in der Mauer, wo man so die Botschaft reinsteckt.
Wenn du auf Wikipedia guckst, gibt es Stäbe, die man in den Boden drückt. Dann gibt es immer noch ein Signal, das irgendwo gesetzt wird. Dass klar ist, der Dead Drop ist gesetzt. Also man kann sich was abholen gehen.
Flagge hoch.
Genau. Und die Dead Drops, die ich da initiiert habe, angefangen habe, das sind eben USB-Sticks, die in der Stadt verteilt werden. Jeder kann einen eigenen Dead Drop machen. Ich habe dann in New York mal mit fünf angefangen.
Was heißt das, USB-Sticks?
Die werden in die Wand eingemauert, sodass nur noch der Stecker rausguckt. Und man kann sich mit seinem Laptop an dem Haus oder der Wand anschließen und was da lassen oder was mitnehmen. Und das Ganze ist ein offline, anonymes File-Sharing, Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerk. Die ersten schlauen, wahrscheinlich auch die ersten schlauen Hörer. Das ist nicht Peer-to-Peer und das ist auch kein Netzwerk, weil das ist nicht vernetzt und so. Aber es geht natürlich um diese Schlagworte. Das Projekt ist ziemlich im Netz rumgegangen. Ich habe damals nur ein Flickr-Set gepostet, Fotos und angedeutet, dass es auch mal eine Anleitung geben wird, dass jeder das selber machen kann. Und dann kam sofort, brach das los, wollten alle machen. Und dann habe ich relativ schnell mit Hilfe so eine Seite aufgesetzt, wo man dann eben seinen Deaddrop sozusagen jetzt ermitten kann. Und dann gibt es eine Karte, wo die alle verzeichnet sind, mit Fotos etc. Und man kann eben zu diesen Orten gehen und die aufsuchen und dann gucken, was andere Leute dahinterlassen haben. Wenn sie denn noch da sind, kann ich auch gleich dazu sagen, das System, was dahinter steckt, ist noch nicht so high-tech ausgereift. Aber wenn so ein Deaddrop ein bisschen älter ist, also es fehlt noch sozusagen der Status, die aktuelle Status-Message, dann kann das natürlich auch gut sein, dass er schon weg ist, entfernt wurde oder kaputt ist oder so.
Also im Prinzip müsste man auch online dann sagen können, in diesem Deaddrop, also in diesen digitalen, toten Briefkasten, liegt jetzt was. Aber es liegt ja, ist man...
Nein, ich würde...
Ja, ist ja mehr so ein Kopie-Effekt. Man tut was rein, aber wenn es jemand draus nimmt, ist es ja immer noch da.
Ja, genau. Das ist ja eben das Schöne, das mit dem digitalen zu kombinieren. Ja klar, also ich habe ja damals in diesem Manifesto geschrieben, oder wusste eben auch, wo ich beschreibe, was das ist, und jeder kann das selber machen und man tut den sozusagen, man setzt den frei in der Stadt und der gehört...
Könnte ich ja eigentlich auch mal machen, ich könnte ja mal so einen Deaddrop machen.
Dann auch keinen mehr. Du kannst dir hier vorne mal einen an die Mauer machen. Ich habe bei mir im Atelier vorne einen an der Wand. Dann könnte ich meinen ganzen Podcast drauf kopieren. Ich habe ganz großkotzig auch dann geblockt irgendwie. Ja, übrigens, ich lese jetzt keine E-Mails mehr. Jeder, der mir was schicken will, dann muss es hier drauf. Und dann war ich weg und dann bin ich wieder gekommen und habe eine Woche schon nicht mehr geguckt. Und dann kam irgendwo ein E-Mail rein von einer Studentin. Ja, ich habe dir was geschickt auf deinen Drop. Irgendwie so, du hast überhaupt nicht geantwortet.
Ja, ich stelle mir vor, man bestellt sich dann auch den Kurierdienst, um dem so eine Datei zu geben. Am besten noch auf so einer 5,25 Zoll Floppy. Und der soll es dann mal bitte in diesen USB-Drop deponieren. Das sind so die Berufsbilder der Zukunft.
Auf jeden Fall, ja. Das interessante war, dass es tatsächlich Ende Oktober losging. Zehn Tage später war Cablegate irgendwie im Gange. Da war es ja eine riesen Diskussion um diese ganze, ja, also mit...... mit WikiLeaks. Ja, ja, und wer da was kontrolliert und das rausschmeißt, weiß nicht, das DNS. Und diese ganzen Interessenflagen, die dann da losging mit, weiß ich nicht, wer kann das Internet abschalten in den USA? Also voll diese Diskussion, hat Obama jetzt den Switch für das Internet oder nicht? Und dann kamen auch die arabischen Revolutionen und Zensur ist ja eh schon lange ein Thema. Also das hat dann plötzlich sehr gut gepasst. Das ist auch zum Beispiel in Frankreich, sind diese Dead Drops auch als Phänomen oder als Movement recht groß. Auch nicht ohne Grund, denke ich, weil Sarkozy da ja auch schon, oder die Politik da groß vorgeprescht ist mit den Three Strikes und dem ganzen Kram, wo Leuten einfach klar ist, ja, ist doch hier offline tauschen und anonym. Und geht halt nicht mal anders ungefähr. Also die Gruppe der User unterteilt sich auch in die von, sagen, begeisterte, ich glaube auch viele auch jüngere Kids, die sozusagen das Abenteuer da dringend, das Ding da dran spannend finden. Ich hatte auch Journalisten am Telefon nie teilweise so, ja, hat sich denn noch nicht schon Apple oder Google bei Ihnen gemeldet? Und ich mir denke so, ja, warum sollten die sich melden? Es ist auch so richtig dicke Werbekampagnen kann man auch nicht machen, weil es ist einfach nicht safe. Also es könnte ja jemanden Dius da drauf tun. Das war auch immer sofort sozusagen das erste Kommentar. Ja klar, kann ja auch jemand machen. Aber wir sind ja eigentlich auch hauptsächlich im Internet eigentlich. Und das ist wieder dieses Ding. Die Leute sitzen halt zu Hause oder nehmen sie einen Stick von einem Freund, stecken ihn einfach rein und denken nicht drüber nach. Beziehungsweise surfen vor allen Dingen im File-Sharing-Bereich auf irgendwelchen Seiten, wo sie ruckzuck irgendwie einen Trojaner haben. Aber man fühlt sich ja sicher, weil ich bin ja zu Hause hier. Das Fenster ist zu, schön warm, aber wenn es draußen auf der Straße, im Dunkeln, nachts, oh, da können ja schon schlimme Sachen passieren, was ja öffentlich erraumt und so. Und die Wahrnehmung darüber, das ist halt wieder dieses Ding, was wir vorhin auch schon hatten. Daran kann man das immer schön erkennen. Und die richtigen Files, Cheryl, auf ihren Blogs, die haben natürlich so, ja, es ist eine zutätige Idee, aber es ist nicht wirklich efficient. Das stimmt natürlich auch. Also, die großen Massen kann man da drüber nicht tauschen. Die Dinge halten nicht für immer, aber es macht Spaß. Also ich habe gerade jetzt auf dem Flug einen Film geguckt, der da drauf war. Man kriegt dann so eine Auswahl an Sachen, die man sich dann anguckt, die man sich sonst einfach gar nicht angucken würde. Und man findet allerlei, also natürlich die klassischen Dinge, Musik und Filme und so.
So wie Fernsehen.
Ja, genau, aber auch einfach nur so eine Reihe von Sonnenuntergängen oder ich weiß nicht, also so absurde Sachen. Privates, Persönliches oder Lokales und so. Wenn man einfach weiß, die Person war auch da und die Leute hinterlassen so Nachrichten in einem Log oder so.
Du hast vorhin hier die Revolution im arabischen Raum und Cablegate erwähnt. Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, dass ich den Zusammenhang so richtig verstanden habe.
Naja, der Zusammenhang da ist. Insofern diese Frage mit, wer kontrolliert sozusagen das Internet oder wo, an welchen Stellen wird mitgeschnitten und mitgehörigt. Und wie kann man das umgehen? Es gab ja auch einige im Freundeskreis, als es losging mit Libyen und Ägypten, und die Leute ja über Hemradio noch, als es sozusagen down war, dann in unterschiedlichster Art und Weise immer noch rauskommuniziert. Ich fand das jetzt total spannend zu beobachten, wo war das jetzt, in Syrien, mit Eseln oder was? Tatsächlich das eine Dorf, das war bei FIFA auf dem Blog, ich habe den ganzen Artikel nicht gelesen, aber eigentlich das Netz ist down, aber es werden Daten und irgendwelche Filme oder Reportagen von Reportern auf dem Landweg rausgebracht, ganz klassisch und solche Sachen. Und sich das anzugucken, wie wird es in Zukunft sein? Alles ist in der Cloud, alles ist irgendwie signiert kontrolliert, den Filmgast darfst du gar nicht haben auf deinem Dropbox, weil den hast du ja gar nicht gekauft und sowieso. Das Gerät hier hat ja auch gar keinen USB-Anschluss mehr, es hat ja auch gar keine Festplatte und so und so. Diese Entwicklung, die hier passiert, einerseits verlieren wir die Kontrolle oder die Hoheit über unsere eigenen Daten und andererseits so spannend sich anzugucken, was gibt es denn für Low-Tech-Mechanismen, um das auf parallel oder so ganz einfach wieder aufzubauen. Und in der Diskussion passt es sozusagen rein, dass das nicht wirklich effizient jetzt ist, bei irgendeiner Revolution über USB-Sticks zu kommunizieren, ist auch klar. Aber wenn es dann halt dein eigenes GSM-Netzwerk ist oder was auch immer, es für Möglichkeiten gibt, Sachen unabhängig eigenständig aufzubauen und irgendwie, dass alles open ist und diese Sachen.
Aber was denkst du denn, wie jetzt so, ich meine jetzt, wie lange, eigentlich sind ja schon ein paar Generationen durch. Es waren bloß am Anfang noch nicht so viele, die jetzt so diese permanente Auseinandersetzung mit dem Internet hatten. Die Digital Natives. Ich bin ja mal ganz beleidigt, wenn Leute sagen, ja die Digital Natives, das sind die, die in den 90ern groß geworden sind.
Da gehören wir nicht zu sozusagen.
Da denke ich mir auf Rechheit hier.
Du bist auch ein Immigrant.
Also die gab es auch schon früher, aber zweifelsohne war es natürlich deutlich weniger. Aber ich kenne das Gefühl halt auch, so dieses.
Die Digital Natives, die können nur die Konsole anmachen und die haben keine E-Mail-Adresse mehr, sondern nur einen Facebook-Account. Und wenn es halt nicht mehr, also so kann man es ja auch sehen, die sozusagen damit so aufwachsen und nur mit den Dingen, die man so drücken kann und die von alleine gehen und wenn irgendwas nicht geht, dann.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt aber nicht das, was ich meine. Es ist eher so dieses, das Netz, beziehungsweise überhaupt die Implikation der Digitalisierung, zu verstehen. Also wirklich so zu verinnerlichen, dass einem manche Sachen auch so klar sind, dass man sie fast schon gar nicht mehr erklären kann. Da ist ja immer so dieser Generationen-Konflikt. So dieses, warum sollte ich denn Meinungsbildung im Internet betreiben? Das ist doch viel zu aufwendig und so. Aber irgendwie, auch wenn man das nicht belegen kann, spürt man so als Nativer, dass das da eigentlich eine Selbstverständlichkeit sein müsste, da hinzukommen. Auch wenn man jetzt noch nicht das System hat, was die Anforderungen erfüllt, denkt man so, geht schon irgendwie. Andererseits gibt es auch so Bereiche, wo einem ganz klar ist, wenn da nicht die normale menschliche Interaktion noch mit dazukommt, dann ist das zum Scheitern verurteilt. So Mailing-Listen-Debatten und so, die meist dazu führen, dass die Leute sich gegenseitig die Köpfe einschlagen oder sich mindestens komplett falsch verstehen. Da fehlt so ein bisschen diese Komponente. Aber wir sind jetzt auf dem Weg, und das ist auch der Grund, warum ich auf deine Sachen interessiert reagiere bzw. einfach auch diese künstlerische Auseinandersetzung, damit ich immer so lustig und anregend finde. Weil du ja im Prinzip genauso diese Selbstverständlichkeiten der digitalen Wahrnehmung in so eine reale Welt siehst und da sie auf einmal irgendwie absurd wirkt.
Also, als du eben ausgeholt hast, am Anfang fällt mir ein dazu, ich habe den Bruce Stirling gesehen, ich habe ihn letztens in Belgrad gesehen, aber auch auf einem Vortrag in Amsterdam mal vor zwei Jahren. Und wo er immer sozusagen, der holt ja auch immer wieder aus mit denselben Themen. Aber er hat das da auch so schön so dargestellt wie ermüdend, dass er auch schon seit Jahrzehnten immer davon das Gleiche erzählt. Und die digitale Revolution ist passiert, ist schon längst passiert. Und es ist schon sozusagen eigentlich ganz viel, es hat ganz viel stattgefunden. Aber wir, gerade wir und vielleicht auch sozusagen die die Natives, sozusagen von noch von vorher, man beschäftigt sich immer noch damit. Also wir arbeiten das immer noch auf, das Ganze. Was also die Auswirkung dessen, sprich also das ganze Copyright und sowieso. Also diese, wie das auch jetzt sozusagen Gesellschaft verändert und auf bestimmte ökonomische Dinge und solche anderen Fragen verändert. Aber wir sind, ja, also ganz viele Sachen sind sozusagen schon längst umgestellt oder es hat schon lange geflippt, aber wir hinken dem noch hinterher bzw. beschäftigen uns damit. Und das, also so sehe ich es ein bisschen auch, oder das haben wir auch schon Freunde gesagt. Ja, das ist schon, oder was ich eingängst auch gesagt habe, dieses digital-virtuell-real- und digital-analog-Gegenüberstellung, das hinkt auf so eine Art, weil das eh alles schon so längst ineinander verzahnt ist und so. Und das, wo sich teilweise sozusagen, oder ja, hier sozusagen die Netzgemeinde sich mit der Politik noch rumschlägt oder den Internet-Ausdruckern und wie es immer so heißt, das ist natürlich immer noch irgendwie, das ist natürlich brandaktuell, aber in anderen Bereichen stellen sich die Fragen ja überhaupt nicht mehr, ob man das jetzt so machen müsste oder nicht, weil das wird sowieso irgendwie online und digital gemacht oder so. Und ja, wie viele Generationen da jetzt sozusagen durchgehen oder, also ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, wie, so wie ich selber oder sozusagen die Art von Netzgenerationen beschäftigt sich ebenso sehr mit dieser Frage und für eine neuere Generation ist es halt, ist es einfach so, ist jetzt nicht so, ist dieses Spiel vielleicht auch schon gar nicht mehr so interessant. Ja, weil, wo seid ihr denn hingeblieben?
Wir verarbeiten immer noch die Krise unserer Jugend.
Ich muss die ganze Zeit Podcasts darüber machen. Nee, aber das ist die Chronistenpflicht. Es bleibt nichtsdestotrotz natürlich aktuell. Und es ist ja auch, also gerade so ein Projekt wie dieses Dead Drops zeigt das ja auch so sehr, das hat so viel Presseanfragen bei mir gegeben, gibt es immer noch. Und einfach dieses Bild von dieser USB, also dieser Datenstecker, der so aus der Mauer guckt, das ist ja auch das, was glaube ich daran so rockt, also so zieht, weil sozusagen Filesharing, Austauschen machen ja eh alle mit einer Festplatte.
Also dieses Sinnbild des hochrobilen, digitalen, abstrakten, eingemauerten, in einem Sinnbild des statischen und digitalen.
Ich mag das so gerne mit, das ganze Haus wird dann sozusagen in dem Moment das Flashdrive. Oder Leute nehmen ihren teuren Laptop und gehen damit irgendwo in der Stadt an einen Kahnstein, wo es vielleicht nass und dreckig ist, und schließen sich da an und wissen gar nicht, was sie da drauf finden und es könnte gefährlich sein. Also mich haben auch Journalisten gefragt, die sich nicht getraut haben, anzuschließen, was sie da machen sollen. Das rüttelt an diesen Fragen. Das ist sozusagen Stadt und alles ganz physisch althergebracht. Und plötzlich hat das da diese konkrete Verbindung. Ich habe mich früher auch ganz viel mit Location-Based Services, hieß das ja mal Anfang der 2000er. Heute heißt das irgendwie Locative Media. Keine Ahnung, wie das jetzt heißt.
Es gibt da ein bisschen ein Sammelsurium an Buzzwords. Das spaltet sich jetzt ein bisschen mehr auf. Mich erinnert das ein bisschen an Geocaching.
Ja genau, Geocacher, die ganze Gruppe hat natürlich da auch, alle haben dazu kommentiert auch, hat natürlich was damit zu tun. Geocaching ist ja so, da geht es ja eher, glaube ich, natürlich geht es darum, diesen Schatz zu finden und sowieso. Es gibt übrigens das Vorbild davon, ist Letterboxing, was aus England kommt, aus Mitte des 19. Jahrhunderts. Sehr interessant, sich das mal anzugucken.
Letterboxing.
Letterboxing ist wirklich, also im Prinzip Geocaching ohne GPS. Aber bei Geocaching geht es ja vor allen Dingen, als sie damals das GPS freigeschaltet haben, um dieses, oh ich kann mich verorten im globalen Grid sozusagen. Ich kann Teil dieser digitalen Karte sein und kann über Koordinaten was finden. Und am Ende findet man halt diesen Schatz oder das Buch und trägt sich ein oder dann ist was in der Dose. Ich habe das selber nie gemacht, aber da geht es tatsächlich um dieses Verstecken. Und bei Dead Drops ist ja eher, die sind ja nicht versteckt. Was ja mitunter ein Problem ist, weil sie dann schnell wieder verschwinden, weil irgendein Troll dann doch vorbeikommt und den dann rauszieht. Aber man muss sie nicht wirklich suchen als versteckt. Und das, was man findet, ist dann digital, im Gegensatz dazu, dass der Weg dahin digital ist.
Man muss sie vielleicht einfach so Ubiquitous machen, dass sie nicht mehr weggetrollt werden kann. Das ist natürlich dann auch eine ziemliche Harakiri-Aktion, aber einfach so den Stick nehmen, da reinballern, zack, bisschen Gips, fertig.
Viele machen halt. Oder die pflegen halt. Also wenn du deinen eigenen hast, dann... Also wenn es sozusagen so eine Art Paten gibt oder so.
Na, man könnte ja einfach an seinen Briefkasten einfach einen anbringen. Der ist dann nicht ganz so tot, aber wenn einem Leute halt digital... Man kennt das ja immer so. Ja, schick's mir doch zu, hier ist meine Adresse. Kann ich dir das nicht digital schicken? Ja, kein Problem. Ich habe auch einen USB-Stick an meinem Briefkasten.
Also wenn du dir einen machst, kriegst du bestimmt was drauf. Ja, mach das mal. Es gibt ja lauter Spin-Off-Ideen gerade. Ich finde es super. Also angefangen von, in Wien wollen jetzt ein Freund Cafetische machen, wo das sozusagen mit eingebaut ist. Es gibt ja so ein bisschen die Regel, ich habe ja aufgestellt, die müssen irgendwie outdoor, also draußen sein und öffentlich sein und auch rund um die Uhr zugänglich sein und so. Es ist natürlich klar, aus Brasilien haben sie ziemlich schnell gesagt, ja, du kannst ja nicht dein Laptop einfach auf der Straße ausparken und so. Je nachdem, wo du bist, ist das nicht so gut. Dann ist der eher schnell weg. Dann machen Leute das auf dem Campus und so. Dann ist der vielleicht irgendwie limitiert zeitlich, aber ist dann ja auch sozusagen okay. Also ich glaube, es gibt ja auch hier im Club ein Indoor, oder? Weiß gar nicht. Ja, ich glaube es auch sozusagen. Also es gibt allerlei...
Ja, aber das Schöne ist, die Dinge entziehen sich einfach dieser Allgegenwart des Netzes. Weil, was nicht, früher war es einfach so schwierig, überhaupt an Informationen heranzukommen. Und wenn man halt von irgendetwas eine Kopie hatte, war das einfach irre. Also allein schon dieses kleine Sammelsurium von lustigen Filmchen, die man mal irgendwo von anderen Leuten Computern runtergekratzt hat. Und dann vergingen so fünf, sechs Jahre. Und mittlerweile, ja, kommen die alle zwei Wochen bei FailBlock, oder sind irgendwie so wohl verlinkt, dass du einfach nur grob bei Google eingeben musst, worum es jetzt, hier gibt es etwas, was ich zum Beispiel, dieses T-Shirt-Folding-Video, dieses japanische, glaube ich.
Okay, das ist an mir vorbeigegangen.
Wo halt, das ist an dir vorbeigegangen.
Ja, siehst du, das ist schon wieder.
Genau, jetzt haben wir nämlich diesen Fall. Jetzt müsste ich das nämlich sozusagen, jetzt müsste ich das nämlich irgendwie finden. Und jetzt kann ich halt überlegen, wie könnte ich das hier, jetzt gebe ich einfach mal Japan-T-Shirt vor den Händen. Natürlich, das ist der erste Link. Und, warte mal, ist das das eine oder ist das das andere? Ich glaube, es ist irgendwie tatsächlich das hier. Ich zeige dir das jetzt einfach mal kurz, ohne das jetzt hier groß einzuspielen. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wann ich an dieses Video kam, aber es war auf jeden Fall so Prä-YouTube-Ära. Und das war ein Schatz auf meiner Festplatte, den ich auch irgendwie zeigen konnte und so weiter. Mittlerweile hat das so seinen Reiz verloren, anderen Leuten Videos zu zeigen, die man auf seinem Computer hat. Und das mag ich jetzt so ein bisschen auch an dieser Deadrop-Idee, dass es so unter Umständen so Dateien gibt, die, wo man sich irgendwo hinbewegen muss, um die dann zu kriegen. Da kommt dieser ganze Aufwand, der ganze Schweiß.
Das macht ja auch alle so verrückt von den Journalisten. Was ist denn da drauf? Und ich sag, dann gibt es immer so ein paar Beispiele, weil die geben sonst nicht Ruhe. Und ich sag dann auch, es gibt diese Regel, man soll auch die Sachen nicht wieder online laden, also nicht hochladen, weil dann ist ja sozusagen der Witz weg, er ist ja offline. Und das ist eben dieses Geheimnis. Und es gibt jetzt, ich weiß nicht, über 400 Deadrops weltweit. Und keine Ahnung, was da drauf ist.
Man könnte ja auch eine super Schnitzeljagd draus machen. Also sozusagen nicht RAM, sondern ROM machst, also Read-Only, USB-Sticks, die du halt verteilst. Und du musst halt immer wieder die Datei runterlesen, um die Informationen zu haben, wo denn der nächste ist.
Ja, es gibt allehand mögliche Gelen.
Mit Rätseln und so. Das finde ich spitze. Und das gibt dem Ganzen auch wieder so einen Spaß zurück, abgesehen davon, dass es halt generell diese spielerische Note hat. Aber es gibt auch so diesen Spaß an der verlorenen Datei wieder.
Es gibt gerade ein Projekt, das ich weiß, ich werde es bei irgendeiner Ausstellung demnächst mal machen. Ich hoffe im Herbst. Ich will unbedingt so eine Katze machen mit so einem SD-Karten-Halsband. Die Katze, die so fast nicht einen Gigabyte mit sich rumträgt.
Eine richtige Katze. Ja, ja.
In der Ausstellung. Die lebt dann in der Ausstellung. Das ist wieder das gleiche. Das Dead Drops ist ja auch im Prinzip daraus her entstanden. Ich hatte dieses Bild und der Stecker guckt aus der Wand. Und, ähm, was tue ich denn da drauf? Was tue ich denn da drauf? Und so, ach ja klar, nichts. Ist Filesharing. Können alle was drauf tun. Und so ist das entstanden eigentlich. Und, ähm, und dann ist Bree auch noch, Bree Fett ist auf den Namen gekommen mit Dead Drops. Und das hat sich so aufadiert, weil das passt ja auch so sehr gut. Und die Katze ist aus einem ähnlichen Stadium. Ich weiß noch nicht genau, was auf dieses Halsband kommt, aber die ist ja auch sehr präsent im Internet, sozusagen. An sich die Katzen, ja.
Jetzt ist nicht die Katze im Internet, sondern das Internet hängt der Katze um das Halsband.
Genau, so ein bisschen, ja. Es ist noch so... Es gibt ja kein 4chan Archiv, aber... Also irgendwas muss da sozusagen, irgendwas Gutes muss da drauf. Vielleicht kann man auch mit der interagieren, aber dann ist es schon wieder zu interaktiv eigentlich. Aber so genau, die Katze, die mit so einem Gigabyte rumläuft, irgendwie mit den ganz wichtigen Files oder so, mit dem Archiv, ich weiß nicht, finde ich eigentlich ein ganz schönes Bild. Und die ist dann halt so in so einer Medienkunstausstellung.
Uns ist das Internet verloren gegangen. Haben Sie eine schwarze Katze gesehen?
In Zukunft wird das alles nur noch über Katzen ausgetauscht.
Ja, Aram, hast du noch ein paar abschließende Gedanken, die du hier dem Ganzen noch unbedingt anfügen möchtest? Mit unserem Versuch hier ein bisschen philosophisch über das Virtuelle und das Grauale.
Ja, wir haben ja vorhin sozusagen so diesen Punkt gehabt, mit man hängt immer noch dieser ganzen Frage nach und eigentlich ist das schon längst alles weiter. Oder sollte man das nicht mehr tun? Natürlich sollte man das tun. Und es gibt auch noch Großteil der Gesellschaft, die haben gerade erst damit angefangen. Also sprich so Google Street View Auto letztes Jahr und so. Genau, ich finde es mir macht Spaß, an dieser Frage ewig zu doktern auf eine Art.
Wie ist es denn eigentlich so mit diesen Künstlern? Vielleicht das noch mal so zum Ausklang. Ich meine, ich weiß ja noch, wie wir so einer Zeit mit dem Blinkenlight in dieser Kunstszene aufgeschlagen sind. Da gab es ja wirklich Verstörungen teilweise. Das müsste sich ja eigentlich mittlerweile auch gewandelt haben, oder?
Ja, das ganze Kunstfeld und verschiedene Kunstrichtungen und wer da wo wie tickt und was macht und was es für nicht ausgesprochene Regeln gibt und so. Das ist ja auch so ein Fass ohne Boden. Man fängt natürlich, ich habe selber ja auch immer, wie sagt man, selbst für mich angefangen, ohne Kunstausbildung und lalala und so. Dann entsteht das sozusagen über die Zeit bzw. den Moment, wo man dann verschiedene mehrere Ausstellungen hatte und dies und das. Irgendwann ist man dann halt Künstler, weil das dann begründet sich das aus sich selbst oder aus dem, was du gemacht hast. Aber die Leute haben, wie du mich am Anfang als Künstler vorgestellt hast, das ist sehr richtig, dann könnte man lange über Medienkunst reden, aus der Ecke, aus der ich eigentlich komme. Aber auch da könnte ich auch viel zu sagen.
Ich habe schon an Steven Kovats gesprochen, ich wollte das ein bisschen außen vor halten.
Genau, das wäre auch richtig. Das finde ich auch gar nicht so spannend. Aber dann werde ich als Architekt vorgestellt oder wenn ich eine Designkonferenz finde, dann stellen die Leute mich als Designer vor. Ich passte auch in viele Schubladen, habe viel auf diesen Webkonferenzen geredet, die dann Google-Map-Marker natürlich super fanden, wo das in den letzten Jahren immer sofort gesehen wurde und auch verstanden wurde. Und in der Kunstwelt fängt das jetzt so an. Dieser Google-Map-Marker ist jetzt gerade, das wird überall angefragt. Und da war eine Art und so, ich weiß nicht, wo auch mal Arbeiten angefragt werden, die für mich vor drei, vier Jahren sozusagen hot waren. Also interessant, weil ich gerade in Tallinn diesen Friends-Workshop gemacht hab, wo man aus Papier so ein Freundebuch baut. Das ist irgendwas zwischen Social Network und Facebook und Poesiealbum mit Stempeln und lauter Tools. Und das jetzt ein, zwei Mal gemacht. Und merke dann halt auch so, ja, das ist eigentlich, das kann man jetzt zwar nochmal sozusagen auspacken, aber wenn ich jetzt was bei Facebook machen würde, müsste man ja auch schon wieder was anderes machen. Beziehungsweise war damals ja immer eher so die Frage, auf welchem Dienst bist du? Heute ist das nicht mehr die Frage, auf welchem Dienst du bist, sondern sind eh alle da. Und dann stellen sich wieder andere Fragen und so. Und insofern ist das ja auch interessant, wie die arbeiten und bestimmte Fragen, wann die wo, bei wem ankommen. Und das ist in der Kunstwelt dann auch unterschiedlich. Und es gibt aber auch eine sehr aktive, seit ein paar Jahren, also eben auch so eine Szene, die sozusagen nicht aus der Medienkunst-Ecke kommt, sondern richtig auch von den, ja, was heißt richtig, aber von den Kunstunis oder erbildene Kunst kommt, die sehr viel Netz-Sachen machen. Also Junge oder Netzkunst hat sich ja auch in den 90ern, Anfang der 1000, da verabschiedet so ein bisschen oder ist in der Versenkung verschwunden. Aber es gibt also, ja, ihr kennt alle die Tumblers und Animated Gifts, weiß ich nicht. Es gibt ja am Monster viel Zeug, was da sozusagen herumgeistert. Und da gibt es einige Leute, die ziemlich intensiv da digital arbeiten und vor allen Dingen nur digital arbeiten. Und das ist spannend, sich anzugucken. Also auch so eine neuere Generation, die das ja viel selbstverständlicher benutzt.
Wo man die ganze Diskussion um die Verschmelzung zwischen dem realen und dem virtuellen gar nicht mehr führen muss vielleicht.
Ja, ich meine, die sind sich dem natürlich auch bewusst. Und das kommt dann immer wieder vor allen Dingen dann ins Rollen, wenn es um Kunstmarkt geht, weil das Bild, das an der Wand hängt, das wird natürlich eher gekauft als eine Webseite. Aber es gibt eben auch Künstler, die verkaufen Webseiten. So, inzwischen. Verkaufen Webseiten? Ja, UALs, mit einer Arbeit drauf. Ich finde das sozusagen eigentlich eine gute Sache. Damit sich der Käufer das dann in sein Internet reinhängen kann, oder was? Das interessante ist, dass es die Story von Jodi, das sehr bekannte Netzkunst-Kollaboration aus Holland, die in den 90ern sehr bekannt geworden sind und auch immer noch sehr gute Arbeiten machen, gute Freunde sind. Die haben das MoMA in New York wollte von denen eine Arbeit haben, eine frühe Arbeit. Das sind alles Webseiten eigentlich. Und die wollten das in ihre Collection aufnehmen und offline nehmen, weil es dann ja in der Collection ist. Das ist ja ganz logisch. Da haben die gesagt, nein, das machen wir nicht. Dann kriegt ihr die Arbeit nicht.
Die Webseite haben und dann offline nehmen, weil sie es dann in ihrem Dead-Drop abgelegt haben.
Was auch immer. Das ist schon eine Errungenschaft, wenn man Sammler eine Arbeit kaufen, die online ist und die einfach online bleibt, weil sie sozusagen online ist. Natürlich kann man sich dann über Kunstmarkt unterhalten. Leute kaufen ja am Ende nur Zertifikate und ich weiß nicht was. Auch bei anderen Arbeiten ist das so. Diese Denke, dass es nicht ein Unikat ist und es es nur einmal gibt, sondern dass sich das viele Leute immer angucken können und trotzdem, dass vielleicht einer als Sammler hat oder eine gewisse Edition davon gibt, finde ich auf jeden Fall spannend. Spannender als das immer dann auszuprinten, an die Wand zu hängen und zu sagen, das haben wir jetzt ausgeprintet und deswegen kann man es verkaufen. Dann bricht es immer und dann wird es immer schwierig. Du hast auch so interessante Sachen gemacht, jetzt habt ihr das so in das Format überführt, damit es wieder handelbar wird und dann verliert es sehr viel dadurch.
Ja, Aram, zu weit schleifig, das wird vielleicht auch gar nicht erst werden, aber ich fand das jetzt mal eine schöne Gedankenanregung und auch eine schöne Zusammenfassung von den Sachen, die du da gemacht hast, wo ich auch finde, die auch für sich genommen immer so ausreichend bahnbrechend waren. Also gerade das mit dieser Map, das ist ja schon fast ikonisch.
Ja, das ist irgendwie ein Klassiker auf jeden Fall.
Insofern soll ich vielen Dank.
Ja, ich danke auch.
Und das war's. Hier Chaosradio Express. Heute mal nicht so eine ausschweifende Sendung. Und ja, nicht so eine Hardcore-Technik-Thema, aber das kommt bestimmt auch wieder.
Wie lange haben wir denn gemacht?
Eineinhalb Stündchen.
Ach doch, ja.
Dann doch schon.
Wahnsinn.
Das geht hier noch nicht als ausschweifende Sendung. Was? Das Internet ist groß, da ist viel Platz auf den ASP-Sticks. Dann geht eine Menge rein. Das war's.